qui que vous soyez votre corps c'est
cette galère votre coeur
c'est ce tambour et votre dieu c'est la
gloire de reprendre la barre
combien de temps et tu rester esclave
cinq ans comment t'appelles-tu baignait
la famille était l'une des plus
respectées le jérusalem mais nous avons
été trahi par mon propre frère
mais ça là tu sais qu'on n'a rien fait
de mal rome veut tu sens que si fier
l'aisne le monde dans lequel tu vie
appartient à rome leurs lois leurs
pouvoirs je ne laisserai pas mourir
impunis je veux qu'il paye pour ce qu'il
nous a fait un moyen dans l'arène
il n'y a pas de loi citons frais fait la
fierté de rome en le battant tu vaincras
un empire qui n'aurait pas dû revenir tu
aurais dû me tuer
ou bien toi
pour allier à finir
gardiens mourir
tu as que tu voulais mon frère moi
toi